stattlich du
juni das ist okay das leben ist ja auch
einfach nicht so einfach wie man sich
das mal vorstellen war halo ist wieder
einmal waren willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja es ist lange her
und ja es tut mir sehr leid und nein ich
also keine lakritze und das letzte video
weiß auch nicht möglich ein typisches
unheilbare video wenn man das so sagen
kann meine zahn zwischendecke wurde
endlich korrigiert also ich hatte dann
eine altes bildung könnten jetzt helfer
färbt über die jahre einfach süß ein
neuer tanz für alle die sich mal
aufgeregt haben dass wir wollen meine
täter dunkel
jetzt sind sie ist nicht mehr olli wie
mich geschnitten habe ich aber lieber
nicht was ich getan so es geht um meine
haare natürlich ich habe kein anderes
thema mehr in meinem leben kommen was
ist das haare interessieren mich nur
noch ich hab strähnchen in meinen haaren
kann er traf aber aus gewaschen und dann
sieht noch so blanc gestrichen
und ich hasse es nötig ich habe meine
haare gerade so sehr die länge ist voll
okay das liebe ich dieser mann blog des
bin auch einfach ich ich kann mich
dagegen auch nicht mehr werden ich meine
ich habe mir ton gekauft und mich und
damit ein video zu drehen sondern privat
und weil so ein youtuber halt echt keine
anderen probleme im leben hat werden wir
uns heute die premiere kümmert das ding
ist moment vom entfernungs video hatte
ich schon vorsichtshalber so dunkle
haarfarbe gekauft und jetzt die frage
mache ich jetzt einfach meine haare
wieder dunkel und alles war umsonst oder
gehe ich jetzt noch mal zu rossmann oder
lassen wir den holy spirit ich weiß
erinnert ihr euch noch an meinen pendelt
wir werden einfach meine der hvb pendeln
irgend will ich nicht gucken kann ich
nicht einfach mal aus dem herzen
entscheiden was ich auf meinem kopf
haben will ich weiß dass ich das nicht
haben will aber ihre spende kann es sein
dass ich nicht weiß wer ich bin und was
ich will und wo mein weg mich hinführen
wird vielleicht diese spende soll ich
meine haarfarbe so lassen ganz klares
nein soll meine haare blond werden nein
soll meine haare dunkel werden das ist
ein klares jahr
wir beraten
und ich denke wir gehen jetzt einkaufen
ja ich verlass viel zu wenig meine
wohnung wir gehen jetzt einkaufen und
falls sich gefragt was ich zu den
letzten wochen gemacht habe eine sache
muss ich euch noch zeigen
ich habe lama kellogg's gefunden ok ich
fahre nach dem icty schüsse konnte
die sbb gegen james 3 j brand
es wurde mahagoni und ich weiß nicht
warum ich das hier gekauft habt
haarfarbe und intensive spülung in einem
das ist ein käsebrötchen groß ist wie
direction wenn ich das ist aber auch
meine haare klatsche
wenn die dann nicht weiß ich dachte das
ist so zum weiß machen wir hier so nicht
glaubt dass man total geil das ist das
ist ein käsebrötchen im käsebrötchen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich mal ganz kurz umziehen
siemens 3 wieder in meinem friseur salon
man auch wirklich erhöhen
besser für das schmeckt ja nich mal
schokolade
ich habe sogar dieses mal vorgesorgt und
magazine geholt um ein richtig schöner
friseursalon zu sein und da dachte ich
gebe ich doch mal neun euro 90 5 magazin
aus und dann habe ich noch so zweimal
spirituelle hre
es kann jetzt auch nasenbär oakley sein
schönes sind sehr lang ist
welche farbe hättest du gerne und am
schnellsten was ändern
[Musik]
der muss eigentlich für mehrkanal muss
ich das irgendwann mal drauf haben weil
ich liebe oakley ist ganz unironisch
aber ich kann es dafür den ball selber
runden welche frisur es zu den eher
dunkles mahagoni habe ich
zufälligerweise drin da und damit würde
ich sagen herzlich willkommen in meinem
friseur salon und es geht jetzt los
also gleich so das macht man auf und
dreht dann dass man nur mit salami
dieses video fühlt sich sehr freuen
das unternehmen steht höheren
bildungsgrad vielleicht dann geht gar
nicht pervers haben wir nur die haare so
in unserem friseur lang haben wir wochen
ganz ohne jede stadt
ich mache mein klo 2 und ja ich habe ein
kluger problem damit jeder gast bei mir
zu hause ist muss diesen cloer
kommentieren
[Musik]
das ist nicht passiert mir die haare ist
aber ganz schön das thema haare färben
und sie nicht nur in verden
das wäre auch mal hier so ein richtiges
ergebnis bekommen nach schottland fahren
ich habe auch überlegt länger in
schottland zu wohnen also mindestens so
monat oder 2 ich glaube ich sollte mir
aber einfach vor das land angucken das
zu entscheiden
oder halt blauäugig einfach hin und dort
bleiben aber wenn ich mir dann halt
überhaupt nicht gefällt
tja dann habe ich dann und ich meine
wenn ich ziemlich jugend zufälliger
weise treffen klar freuen wird es
mächtig erwarte es jetzt aber nicht so
zu 100 prozent
seht ihr schon irgendwas gibt schon
gefällt warum als andere youtuber somit
57.000 abos die fernen sich jedoch nicht
mehr mit druck nie zurück die haare
aber ich leute ich bin noch eine frau
des volkes ich färbe sich selbst um sie
dann von dem friseur wieder retten zu
lassen aber erstmal färbe ich sie mir
selbst was wir aber auch ein bisschen
beeilen weil ich habe heute noch ein
prämie
[Musik]
keine ahnung wo ich dahin gespritzt
ok dann weg ein teppich im badezimmer
keine ahnung warum hat so fade optik
nicht ist da haarfärbemittel
draufgekommen ich werde es nicht raus
krieges heißt wieder zählte scheint ja
ich hab ein termin für etwas was man
aufnehmen muss mit einem mikrofon mehr
verrate ich noch ledig leicht beim
nächsten mal dinkla
ich glaube wird die farbe voll bis wir
uns den hahn schon wieder antun wollte
wurde zehnter der action farben kaufen
sie alle zusammen geschnitten dass auf
kopf und ich wundere mich warum mein
haar nicht
bleibt noch die zweite paarung drauf und
dann sehen wir gleich wieder
ja und jetzt müssen wir warten
und während wir warten viele mit
magazinen schottland schön in schottland
gibt es einen buchladen in dem man
wohnen kann und dann muss man bücher
also die preise für die bücher die sie
verkaufen müssen sie selbst schätzen
kosten für die übernachtung und
buchhändler spielen etwa 50 euro pro tag
ein bisschen geduld müssen sie noch
mitbringen bis 2000
an sich ist openbook ausgebucht einmal
im jahr wird neue highlight show das
schönste nutzt ihrem land gekrönt und
18.1 gratis black face schied wie kommt
es dass manche menschen lebenslang
verbunden bleiben mit dem ort an dem sie
aufgewachsen sind und andere ihm
entkommen wollen
wann beginnt ein mensch sich heimisch zu
fühlen wann hört er damit auf das ist
schön den ort an dem man aufwächst nicht
zu verlassen ist leicht und schwer
zugleich leicht wenn man sich keine neue
identität erarbeiten muss schwer weil
man sie sich nicht bearbeiten kann
die schottische sängerin zufällig kammer
und ich würde sagen wir waschen jetzt
aus über den kopf hebt an zu jugend ich
habe mich von bertrandt mein letztes
wegen muss sich an kann durch zum
abwaschen kragen
[Musik]
hier lernt haben wir stolz sein kann auf
die waage das ist 20 meter zugelegt
wer husten meine will man da jetzt
wissen alle dass ich eine bin sehr
gespannt ich meine haare und nägel gut
an mein gott warum sind sie so weit käme
auswaschen und die sich so scheint
[Musik]
ich habe diese strähnchen sogar hass
entspannt ist ein sport bh geben sondern
seht ihr auch überall leute im bikini
wieder top
[Musik]
und sind sie tragen ja was sagt ihr wie
findet ihr es sogar sagen weil das
oberteil wird jetzt irgendwie habe ich
würde wieso und yogalehrerin und jetzt
wirklich auch noch billiger wäre das ein
jude war dieser haarfarbe die richtige
entscheidung das ist ein klares ja
und wenn euch das video gefallen hatte
text mit einem blutigen daumen nach oben
und jetzt abonniert meinen kanal und
aktiviert die glocke folgt mir auf
instagram twitter und switch und
abonniert meinen laut schwarze mehrkanal
da kommen bei videos keine sorgen
versprochen ist versprochen
[Musik]